Pour ne louper aucune vidéo,
abonnez-vouset activez la petite cloche !
Salut les Épicurieux.
Connaissez-vous l'originede l'expression
« le jeu en vaut la chandelle » ?
Je vais vous éclairer.
C'est une expression que l'onutilise
quand nous faisons quelque chose qui en vaut la peine.
Est-ce que raconter l'originedes expressions
de la langue française, par exemple,
en vaut la chandelle ?
Je pense que ouicar derrière le mot se cache toujours
un peu de notre histoire et de notre culture.
Mais quelrapport avec la chandelle ?
L'origine de cette expression remonte à une ancienne pratique.
A une époque où il n'y avait pas d'électricité
ni d'écrans pour occuper les soirées.
Danstous les milieux riches ou modestes,
on se rendait les uns chez les autres
pour jouer auxcartes ou aux dès
et on pariait.
Pour l'éclairage, chacun apportait une chandelle
ou versait unecontribution à l'autre.
Même s'ils ne jouaient pas pour de l'argent,
tous les joueurs espéraientque les gains
compenseraient le montant des bougies.
L'expression s'est ensuite transposée
authéâtre.
L'éclairage des salles obscures
coûtait très cher aux compagnies.
Il fallait doncque la pièce remporte du succès,
qu'il y ait beaucoup de spectateurs
pour que la recettecouvre le coût de l'éclairage.
C'est clair ?